Ok so The Batman gives us a showdown for the
ages in which the Dark Knight faces off against
The Riddler in a battle that spans Gotham. Batman
eventually learns the whereabouts of the character
towards the end of the film after he snipes
Falcone from his apartment window. However,
he actually could've caught him sooner had
he paid attention to the photos of the Mayor.
These were clearly taken from a high vantage
point overlooking the Iceberg Lounge which we
later find out is Edward Nashtons home. We even
get a wide shot of the club at one point and in
the top corner can see Nashton looking out of his
window taking photos of the lounge. Had Batman
figured out where abouts the photos were taken
he could've caught Nashton sooner and the movie
would've been ten minutes long which...yeah not
as fun as what we got. Sorry for ruining your day.
Now this is very much a Year Two story in which
Batman is completely inexperienced so we can
excuse this. He makes mistakes throughout
the film and another major one is that he
refuses to accept the Bruce
Wayne side of his personality.
Though I've seen people complaining about
this, I actually think it's the whole
point of the movie and had he embraced it he
would've learned about Renewal a lot sooner.
Early on Alfred tells Bruce that the
accountants from Wayne Manor want to
meet with him as Wayne Enterprises is getting
into serious issues. This is likely because it's
hemmoraghing cash in order to line the pockets
of Falcone and the corrupt people in Gotham.
Had Bruce met with them he could've learned
the truth early on and then he wouldn't have
had to discover it through Edward Nashton
who also just happens to be an accountant.
I absolutely love this detail and
it shows that Bruce's stubborness
is somewhat his downfall. I think going forward
that it's reasons like that which is why he will
need to do a Bruce Wayne begins movie
and basically step back into the light.
This idea is showcased in the film itself
as when he first sees Sunlight he squints
because of how bright it is whereas at
the end of the movie he looks up the
sun without shifting his gaze because he's
finally ready to become a beacon of hope.
I don't think it'll be long before Bruce
Wayne introduces himself to the world and
speaking of introductions I've just
realised I haven't told you who I am.
(I am weed)
What...no this is The Heavy Spoilers show,
I'm your host Paul aka Dickhead Grayson
and this video we're gonna be making a
Harvey Dent on Youtube with our atrocious
puns and insane details from the movie.
I don't think these easter eggs have been
brought up in any other breakdowns and if
you enjoy it we'd massively appreciate the
thumbs up button. With that out the way,
thank you for clicking this, now
let's get into the rest of the video.
Ok so the movie opens up with The Riddler
spying on The Mayor's son before he moves
into the home to murder the main man. This
young boy is dressed in a red ninja costume
and throughout the film Bruce encounters
him several times. I'd love to see this kid
become Robin at some point and we learn that
he found his parents dead much like Bruce did.
The Mayor's death scene is a big one and
we actually see some major Parrallels
here between The Riddler and Batman.
Much like he steps out of the shadows,
The Riddler does too and the characters
even carry some similarities in their masks.
Placing them side by side we can see
that the nose pieces are very similar
and they of course are both geniuses that
want to take down the corrupt in Gotham.
This is symbolises in the Riddler's
apartment later on in which Batman sees that
he has one Bat in a cage. Just below it there are
several rats and this very much represents Batman
and Gotham. He is hanging above as it's sole
protector whilst the corrupt rats scurry below.
Now the film culminates with
the Seawall being destroyed
which floods Gotham. However this is actually
foreshadowed early on at the Mayor's home.
During the debate with Bella Real
he says that she wants to gut the
Renewal project fun which will mean
that vital seawall funds are also cut.
Beyond this though we can also catch a
newspaper wall chronicling Don's wins
and if you zoom in on the one below the L
in lies, you can catch a mention of this.
It asks whether the Seawall construction has been
stalled and due to the greed of the corrupt in
Gotham it's turned it into a weak
point that the Riddler exploits.
From here we cut to Gotham and get Bruce's
narration, the shot of him walking through
the streets is akin to Batman Year One in which
he walked downtown on his first mission. Amongst
these flashes of criminals in the city we get
one robbing The Good Times Grocery Store. Now
there's been several videos that have pointed out
this is a nod to the Robert Pattinson movie Good
Time. Matt Reeves cast Rob after watching this
so it's a really nice detail. However I haven't
seen anyone point out yet that the robber himself
actually wears similar clothes to what Pattinson
had on in the film including a grey hoody
with a orangey red jacket over the top of it.
After Batman beats up the black and white
gang he then travels to the Mayors office and
the shot of him walking in heavily mirrors how
the police looked at Clarice Starling when she
did it in the silence of the lambs. Later on when
Batman confronts The Riddler in Arkham we also
get similar framing to when Clarice met Hannibal
Lector and as Batman says...it's all connected.
Now Reeves has been clear about the
influences that he had when producing
this film. This includes Zodiac, Seven and
Halloween. Huge shoutout to Ryan Arey for
pointing out that the opening somewhat
mirrors Michael Myers introduction
as we watch things through a first person point
of view. Bearing the Halloween influence in mind
I went back and rewatched the movie and we
also get a scene where Michael sits in the
back of someones car before murdering them which
massively plays on when Riddler does it to the DA.
(shut the f**k up Ryan Arey)
Shoutouts Greg from Reel Rejects for also
pointing out that the opening is very similar
to the 70s movie The Conversation
which also centres around a voyeur.
There's several voyeur shots in the movie such as
when we see Bruce walking through the crowd. This
is shot all from behind as is the moment where he
removes his motorbike helmet. This bit is mirroed
when we see his back scars and he walks along
which is then coupled by us following Gordon from
behind. It's a really cool aesthetic that makes
us feel like we're following the characters too.
Now everything is all a plan for the Riddler to
get Falcone, the mob boss that runs the entire
city. Every iteration of tv and film before
this has pronounced it Falcone however here I
think that they purposely changed up the
pronunciation so that it's closer to falcon.
Riddler describes the character
as a Rat with wings which,
though typically a bat could
also be a not to a Falcon.
Riddler wants Batman to bring the Mob boss out of
the club so that he can snipe him from his window
and in his final few moments it's possible that
Falcone recognises Bruce. Earlier in the movie he
references a moment that was shown in the Long
Halloween in which he was taken to Wayne Manor
after being shot. Falcone said that as he was
being operated on that Bruce looked down at him
and this moment is very much mirrored here.
He was initially supposed to die then but
was saved by Thomas Wayne and here is his
actual death that Bruce failed to stop.
It's a brilliant way to mirror the
characters and it's also in this
light that we see Falcone's cut on his
face. This was given to him by Selina
which is a reference to Batman Year One in
which she also did the same thing to him.
He also mentions Zorro at one point
which was the film in the comics that
Bruce and his family went to see
before they were shot and killed.
We learn in the film that he possibly had the
Wayne's killed after Thomas asked him to silence
a journalist and on screen the words 'Hush'
appear. The Journalists surname is also Elliot,
which is all likely a reference to Thomas
Elliot aka the villain Hush in the comics. Now
DC recently released an animated movie based
on the graphic novel but rather than keeping
Elliot as part of it they revealed at the
end that it was The Riddler behind it.
You can interpret that the Riddler is
actually the son of the journalist who was
murdered by Falcone potentially making
him and Bruce even more similar than
initially suspected. They are both called
Edward and though it's never confirmed,
I do kinda feel like the whole Hush
connection and Riddler thing might be there.
In the photo we see of him as a
child he's also in a choir which
makes sense as to why the song Ave Maria
pops up so many times in the movie.
We see a cease and desist letter that is
sent to him and along the top you can catch
the names Miller and Moore which are both
a reference to Frank Miller and Alan Moore.
Both of which made some seminal graphic
novel stories in Batman Year One,
The Dark Knight Returns and also The Killing Joke.
Not long after the Police find Riddler in a
cafe and they slam his head against the counter
which cracks his glasses. This crack can
actually be seen in all the appearances
he makes from this point out and I love this
attention to detail from the costume department.
You can also catch that his costume has
cellophane wrap behind his mask so that he
doesn't leave any DNA behind for Forensics
to find. Apparently this detail is also in
the Funko pop...but I dont really know
what they are so, yeah, maybe I guess.
His gang end up attacking Bella Real
after the explosives go off and there's
actually a split second line in
the movie that foreshadows this.
When Batman is attempting to take
the collar off of Gil Colson we can
see the Riddler is livestreaming the whole thing.
Amongst the comments is one that
says 'hope its a dud and we gotta
do it all again tuesday' which sets up the
attack that comes at the end of the movie.
Gil Colson's licence plate is S39 7WD
which could be a reference to Batman's
first appearance in Detective Comics 27 which
was released in 1939. Many of the officers in
the movie are from the 39th Precinct as well
and like Batman says...it's all...all connected.
Now we're wrapping up the video because I've
gotta go watch the movie for a fifth time but
just a little bit of trivia for you, did you
know Zoe Kravitz also voiced Catwoman in the
Lego Batman movie. There's also...also
a bit where Penguin gets tied up and
he waddles like a penguin so...got those, Inane
details in this insane details breakdown too.
Now I'd of course love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let me know.
If you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
perfect scene in Spider-Man Homecoming.
We break down the entire thing so it's
definitely worth checking
out if you wanna know more.
With that out the way thank you
for sitting through the video,
I’ve been Paul and I’ll see
you next time. Take care, Peace